les Bleus s'imposent c'est une victoire
27 à 12 face à l'Uruguay mais doit-on
s'en satisfaire pas sûr nous sommes là
pour en parler pour débriefer ce second
match deuxième match de l'équipe de
France dans cette Coupe du monde de
rugby marque feuillet merci d'être ici
directeur général du Figaro je suis
parti beau je vous ai senti tendu dans
cette fin de rencontre c'est-à-dire que
on abordait ce match avec beaucoup
d'intention on voulait une victoire
franche on voulait tester un certain
nombre de joueurs Fabien Galtier avait
fait tourner son équipe et puis au total
qu'est-ce qu'on a vu une très belle
équipe uruguayenne très valeureuse qui
tenait le ballon qui multipliait les
séquences de jeu et à la fin une équipe
de France à la peine et on a les quatre
points de la victoire ce qui est quand
même est le premier motif de
satisfaction mais je crois que c'est à
peu près la seule chose dont on peut
être satisfait à l'issue de ce match
vous on en espérai 5 haute barietty
journaliste au service société du Figaro
passionné de rugby vous vous êtes dans
quel état d'esprit à 22h55 l'essentiel
est assuré c'est on aurait aimé on
aurait aimé que la victoire soit
bonifiée qu'elle passe à 5 points au
lieu de 4 d'ailleurs
après cette course folle et puis
finalement annuler c'est vrai qu'il y a
eu plusieurs essais annulés ce qui est
en plus entretien un peu le la
frustration moi je pense qu'il faut
quand même saluer l'Uruguay qui n'avait
quand même il faut dire rien à perdre
18e nationale rien à perdre sur un match
comme ça qui a tout donné qui a collé au
ballon et qui nous a quand même posé de
sérieux problèmes je pense que là il va
avoir du travail avant de rencontrer la
Namibie et puis l'Italie merci d'être
ici journal
pour vous le job est fait ou pas non
pas de chance sur le laisser de Macalou
qui en plus sur une règle un peu
compliqué où il fallait qu'il gratte le
ballon avec le pied avant et donc ça
reste c'est un juste mais la règle
semble respecter mais sinon l'essentiel
n'est pas là au cas remplaçant de la
semblait briller à part on en parlera
peut-être après Antoine stoï ou quelque
chose
la première chose à dire aussi parce
qu'on a on a souvent
cet excès de d'orgueil mais c'est
surtout l'Uruguay l'Uruguay qui a été
propre qui a joué propre dans les rocks
généralement le manque d'expérience très
haut niveau et notamment en première
division en Europe peu importe
ce manque d'expérience peut se voir dans
les rocks et sur le sur le plan physique
ça pêche souvent au bout d'un certain
temps et même à la mêlée
vous regardez c'est du 55 ans dans les
équipes qui sont pénalisées que ce soit
la France ou l'Uruguay 27 12 quasiment
le même score que contre les Blacks je
m'inquiéterais si j'étais les
Néo-Zélandais après cette jolie
performance de l'Uruguay nous sommes en
direct évidemment sur Le Figaro.fr nous
sommes aussi sur Youtube c'est une
première réaction Adam Beckett une
performance discutable nous dit-il c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire on sera à
Lille dans un instant à temps Vincent
roseron avec nos envoyés spéciaux pour
nous dire ce qu'il a vu lui c'est
toujours un peu différent ce qu'on voit
dans le stade et ici oui c'est vrai ils
avaient pas le même pas le même avis que
nous en tout cas on a vu un stade
bouillon
ils pourrons nous le raconter aussi là
il y a pas de doute qui a sifflé parfois
l'équipe de France ouais si vous trouvez
que c'est bien sûr et qui a chanté la
Marseillaise juste après
est-ce que alors on oublie les points la
victoire est-ce qu'on a été décevant
dans le jeu sur toute la ligne où il y a
des petits points on peut dire allez là
on a été pas mal Augustin j'ai trouvé
que au fur et à mesure du match on
n'était plus rapide dans les
transmissions mais on a eu beaucoup de
mal au début Maxime Luc a toujours du
mal à lâcher son ballon vous l'aimez pas
non non
vous avez droit d'avoir un avis tranché
voilà je trouve que la rentrée batisse
couillou est loin d'être honteuse moi
j'ai trouvé que les finisseurs avec un
fait du bien on a senti que wordy était
sur la lancée de son match contre les
Blacks on a senti peut-être on en
parlera plus tard mais les joueurs qui
avaient leur place à gagner Makalu a
quand même marqué les esprits
on l'a vu on a toujours su qu'il était
très complet en ce qui peut jouer 7 8
centre ailiers d'ailleurs Martin avait
bien fait de préciser que ce n'était pas
le joueur le plus c'était le joueur le
plus rapide des Bleus Martin couture ce
n'était pas vieille barré ben on l'a vu
tout à l'heure avec une très bonne
course qui malheureusement termine mal
est-ce qu'on a été décevant sur toute la
ligne Aude moi c'est vrai que j'ai du
mal voilà la victoire les quatre points
mais à part ça j'ai du mal à trouver des
motifs de satisfaction la touche
notamment c'est une de mes phases que je
préférais à titre personnel
on a eu beaucoup de déchets énormément
on y reviendra peut-être aussi de
pénalité alors l'Uruguay aussi on n'est
pas les seuls sur ce point mais beaucoup
trop de pénalités à ce niveau
international les mêlés c'était pas
formidable non il y a pas je sais pas si
vous serez d'accord avec moi mais il y a
pas beaucoup de motif de satisfaction
sur le contenu du jeu le contenu
je rejoins haut de la conquête a été
défaillante on a été de manière assez
surprenante pénalisée en mêlée
des touches pas droites des rock mal
maîtrisés beaucoup de fautes on a été
sanctionné par l'arbitre et ça c'est ce
qui va falloir rectifier très vite dès
la Namibie parce que ça a été une des
forces de l'équipe de France notamment
contre les All Blacks et on sait qu'une
équipe ne peut remporter ce type de
compétition que si elle n'est pas
pénalisée et si elle a une bonne
conquête faut recommencer à rebâtir une
conquête eff ça commence devant ça
commence devant évidemment et ce point
de vue là les Uruguayens ont été
épatants je trouve je sais pas si vous
avez vu le match Angleterre Argentine
mais l'Argentine a été incapable
d'enchaîner les temps de jeu sauf à la
toute fin du match et là on a vu une
équipe régulière avoir les valeurs de
l'Argentine le courage l'esprit
collectif la vaillance et en même temps
être capable devant l'équipe de France
d'entraîner d'enchaîner les temps de jeu
d'attaquer systématiquement avec le
ballon et et je crois qu'on peut leur
donner un grand coup de chapeau et
attention quand on se fait pénaliser je
le mets juste parce que on pense
toujours que les le jeu au pied et les
points au pied ça ne suffit pas pour
gagner un match l'Angleterre les 27
points comme ça oui c'est vrai en plus
trois drops donc attention à ça parce
que c'était justement notre force et
plus particulièrement depuis deux ans
beaucoup de fautes de la part de la
France nous dit la kill sur Youtube on
part à Lille Vincent roseron vous étiez
dans dans le stade alors vous êtes fait
plaisir moins que vendredi dernier
j'imagine
alors je vous avoue que à la mi-temps je
suis allé voir jean-marconnor et je lui
ai demandé alors tu en penses quoi les
matchs et il m'a répondu on est plutôt
sur une purge comme on dit il m'a dit ça
alors je sais pas si c'est si ça a
continué comme ça pendant tout le match
selon lui mais on n'a pas pris autant de
plaisir que la semaine dernière non
c'était du très mauvais rugby soyons
clairs c'était c'était extrêmement
mauvais et on a pas reconnu l'équipe de
France pour une fois c'est les absents
qui ont raison ils n'ont pas tort
c'est-à-dire que
le discours de qualtier me semble très
optimiste sur la sur la le niveau de son
équipe générale on voit très bien que
ceux qui étaient là ce soir n'équivalent
pas ceux qui étaient là contre les
Blacks c'est pas la même équipe du tout
les avants ont été brouillon désordonnés
alors qu'il dominait au début on n'a pas
resserré le jeu c'était c'est vraiment
brouillon et franchement j'entendais les
points au pied la vaillance des
Uruguayens je souscris mais franchement
vous regardez chaque fois que les
Uruguayens sont allés en touche
s'ils avaient tenté les pénalités je
sais pas qui aurait gagné ce match oui
parce que c'est la référence je me suis
fait à 55e où on se dit ah ils
reviennent parce que il y a un vrai
moment où il revient à un point et là on
se dit ouh là en fait on peut perdre et
en plus on se rappelle toutes les fois
où ils sont là en touche ou ça ils ont
perdu derrière alors que en fait ils
auraient pu complètement être à au moins
9 points devant les Bleus au blanc
c'était une soirée pénible et on a pas
reconnu les Bleus
vous êtes sortis vendredi dernier
show-bouillon beaucoup moins visiblement
vos amis une petite veste il fait froid
à Lille
il fait disons que si vous voulez qu'on
va vous faire la météo là mais il fait
nettement plus frais qu'à minuit enfin
11h du soir à Saint-Denis il y a une
semaine mais c'est complètement c'est
complètement supportable en tout cas en
tout cas c'est déjà plus supportable que
vendredi mais il fait pas il fait pas
non plus il fera que ça on a pris une
veste on va dire de confort au cas où ça
sera avrilan la soirée un petit peu
est-ce qu'on a eu peur est-ce que vous
avez senti dans le stade un public
craintif un moment un peu tendu est-ce
que vous vous avez eu peur de perdre ce
match
pas vraiment mais encore une fois parce
que ça manquait de lucidité
[Applaudissements]
je ne commande pas sur la laine de ce
sur mon garçon que vous pouvez pas avoir
parce que vous avez pas encore les
odeurs lors des lives sinon pour le pour
votre question ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il y a eu deux moments le moment du
de l'essai
très très simple
de supporters anglais forcément de
moments effectivement le premier c'est
effectivement ce TC ou ils reviennent à
un point et là si movacan marque pas
juste derrière on se dit que là on
pouvait deux on pouvait douter et il y a
un petit moment sur le premier temps qui
a été assez marquant c'est un moment où
en fait le Stade de France c'est
complètement tue il y avait énormément
d'anglais excusez-moi au Stade de France
non on a changé on est à Lille à
Villeneuve-d'Ascq pour être précis le
stade Pierre Mauroy c'est complètement
tué et on a on entendait les yeux
régulières dans le stade pendant 3
minutes on s'est dit ah ça commence un
peu à sentir mauvais on ne va pas être
sûr ils vont démonstration force comme
on disait au début on va leur mettre 85
à deux
c'était un match à 50 points et on s'est
très vite rendu compte puisque à partir
de la 16e minute on a plus rien marquer
en première mi-temps et donc c'était il
y avait un grand trou noir quoi et le
public qui était formidable très bon
public à Villeneuve-d'Ascq enthousiaste
heureux d'avoir les Bleus qui n'ont pas
si souvent ben le stade a été comme
disait Vincent à l'instant le stade
s'étude donc clairement je sais pas s'il
y avait de la peur mais en tout cas il y
avait de l'inquiétude en plateau est-ce
que vous avez eu peur un moment de
perdre ce match alors de perdre non je
dois dire que quand même on est resté
devant tout le long même si c'est vrai
que il y a eu un écart d'un point à
chaque fois que les Uruguayens ont mis
un essai on a recollé très vite donc pas
eu peur de perdre ce match en revanche
ce qui fait peur c'est c'est cette
équipe B c'est la profondeur du banc on
se dit mais derrière notre équipe a en
fait qu'est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce qu'il
reste si on a de nouveau de des blessés
importants qu'est-ce qui va nous rester
si on sort des poules et en phase finale
ça c'est un peu plus inquiétant je
trouve Marc est-ce que vous avez eu un
moment de doute oui on a on a on a quand
même été un petit peu inquiet quand on
voyait que cette équipe n'arrivait pas à
scorer quand on voyait que les
Uruguayens reprenaient confiance et
surtout ce qui nous a troublé
c'est que ça fait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas eu pas vu une équipe de
France à ce niveau médiocre Jean-Marc
l'a dit ça fait longtemps qu'on n'avait
pas vu une équipe de France sans idée
sans leader manquer un peu de manque
d'idée c'est pas vraiment quoi faire on
a la balle on sait qu'on doit aller
poser le ballon derrière la ligne mais
comment on fait pas d'idée un manque de
patron aussi peut-être un manque de
patron très certainement et puis cette
équipe nous avait habitué aussi à être
très pragmatique à être un peu clinique
à revenir de toutes les situations et là
on a eu un doute on s'est dit mais au
fond ça n'accroche pas on ne voit pas le
fil du jeu qui a guidé cette équipe bon
c'est peut-être aussi parce qu'elle a
beaucoup tourné
Fabien Galtier quand même fait une très
grande revue d'effectif en plus les
finisseurs sont rentrés et donc cette
équipe a beaucoup bougé pendant pendant
ce match mais match très décousu et une
équipe de France pas convaincante Chris
Kross l'un des habitudes du Figaro vous
salue Marc et dit que ce fut dur et vous
vous interpelle je pense que vous êtes
d'accord j'ai je vous pose la question
sur Youtube vous dites oui vous dites
NON avez-vous eu peur que le 15 de
France perd ce match donne la réponse
dans un instant j'attends celle
d'Augustin Moriau
il y a eu quelques choses intéressantes
en début de match notamment de la part
de moïfana qui a fait un très mauvais
match au match précédent qui a tenté de
croiser des chisterailles etc et on
s'est fait une remarque pendant le match
pendant qu'on le regardait c'est qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup vu les ailiers non
surtout BIAL barré mais si on n'a pas vu
les ailes
si on l'a pas assez vu c'est parce que
la balle n'est pas arrivé à elle et ça
ça a été assez marquant donc ça ça
rejoint le manque de rapidité dans les
transmissions et puis très peu de
personnes on accompagne pas beaucoup
après les rocks on avait très peu de
phases nombreuses la France faisait
beaucoup ça elle aimait appuyé longtemps
devant la ligne dans les 22 et on a je
crois que notre nombre maximum de phases
devaient être à 8 phases de suite de jeu
et donc on a on a beaucoup manqué
d'idées alors il y a un autre paramètre
aussi à prendre en compte c'est que il
n'y a aucun joueur à côté d'un autre
joueur qui joue dans le même club aucun
joueur ne se connaît dans la même ligne
des Uruguay par exemple
il se connaissent tous d'ailleurs ils
sont tous de la même famille le deuxième
centre et les lieux qui jouent à vin
ensemble c'est vrai vous avez raison on
retourne à Lille messieurs est-ce que le
job est fait c'est la première question
que je posais en plateau vous étiez pas
encore connecté est-ce que on a fait le
travail
moi je pense que non c'était un match
qui est demandé un bonus offensif donc
on est loin du compte il manque un poids
alors on en a quatre on pourrait se dire
quatre points
de confiance quand même
je me répète il y a un problème de
banque et je voudrais souligner aussi
autre chose dans le l'histoire du job de
Sévère on a beaucoup de chance avec le
fameux bunker de Tao FIFA parce que
quand on voit les images au ralenti le
coup d'épaule dans le visage de du d'une
mêlée
uruguayen là il y a une grosse faute et
vous avez vu dans d'autres matchs ça
aurait value rouge donc on a déjà des
problèmes en deuxième ligne on risque on
risque de perdre le plus puissant de
tous
parce que j'ai demandé j'ai demandé en
régie de mettre le gros tracteur de la
double fenêtre marque feuillet Jean-Marc
Bonin Marc feuillet nous a dit en
première mi-temps que non il n'y avait
pas de carton rouge et que l'arbitre
avait bien fait Jean-Marc Kona vous
contre
Jean-Marc on a risqué gros c'est surtout
ça mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
les juges enfin les arbitres interprète
aussi une intention il y a une
maladresse le joueur s'est baissé au
moment où il était plaqué il y a des
disproportions de taille et puis
j'ajoutais ça aussi ça compte le joueur
s'est relevé tout de suite il y a pas eu
de blessures le choc n'était pas violent
il y avait pas mis en danger non plus du
joueur donc voilà
ça aurait pu être un carton rouge
Jean-Marc oui
je suis d'accord sauf qu'il y a quand
même une règle il y a pas de gestes pour
c'est l'épaule il y a pas de mouvement
de bras le
est déjà plaqué par un autre donc Tao
arrive en soutien et donc le soutien
sans mouvement de bras avec l'épaule
directement à hauteur du visage alors je
suis absolument d'accord avec toi sur la
différence de taille c'est une évidence
Aretha est petit tu as occupé et c'est
souvent dans le cas au rugby mais il le
sait c'est un professionnel il a
l'habitude il sait très bien que ça
taille de ce point de vue l'appelant
handicapé et je pense quand même que
dans le mouvement il y a un manque
évident de contrôle je pense qu'il a de
la chance avec l'arbitre vidéo parce que
pour moi c'était évident qu'il allait
prendre en rouge et Arnaud et David qui
étaient à côté de moi redoutait la même
chose et quand on a vu le jaune
apparaître à l'écran on s'est dit il a
été sauvé par le bunker mais l'équipe de
France aurait pu perdre encore un
deuxième ligne pour plusieurs matchs
alors on peut rester sur l'arbitrage
parce que c'était l'un de nos débats à
la mi-temps Jean-Marc laisser
uruguayen pour vous il y avait-il et
c'est de l'Uruguay en première période
vous voulez dire l'essai sur le couteau
[Musique]
encore raté un placage c'est
insupportable et puis après quand on
voit le plan large on voit qu'il y a une
obstruction évidente il y a pas de
d'ailleurs au moment même de l'essai si
vous voyez le ralenti il y a je crois
Anthony jellonge qui lève les bras enfin
on voit que ils ont vu quelque chose les
Français qui qui était une faute
manifeste et effectivement après à la
vidéo c'est clair non non il y a pas de
là c'est pas normal le type prend arrive
Etcheverry arrive tout seul et il y a
pas un défenseur à moins de 2 mètres de
lui c'est bien la preuve que la il y a
une faute avant c'est pas possible on
laisse un trou pareil bon merci
Jean-Marc avez-vous eu peur que le 15 de
France perd ce match vous dites non à
58% ouais il est les internautes et les
Français devant leur télé ont tremblait
faisons le bilan
a commencé avec une équipe complètement
Romanée Augustin quel joueur vous a déçu
déçu
un joueur justement
de la dernière fois et là cette fois-ci
je le défendrai pas non parce que
défensivement il fait les mêmes erreurs
qu'habituellement
il fait toujours la même chose d'aller à
l'intérieur
s'embarquer tout seul et reculer il
recule beaucoup un élu qui recule
beaucoup et puis on attend on attend
beaucoup sur les grattages généralement
là je crois qu'il a gratté un ballon
donc pourquoi pas et puis il a été
pénalisé deux fois je crois de mémoire
donc Gabin Villers très clairement moins
fana qui a baissé en régime alors que
c'est le genre d'équipe contre lequel
ils doivent briller parce que moi il
fallait que le problème c'est que c'est
les deux joueurs qui étaient titulaires
s'ils sont sur le terrain aujourd'hui je
donne une statistique 53% l'occupation
de terrain par l'Uruguay qui sur sur
cette sur cette phase de jeu haute vous
le joueur qui vous a déçu le ou les
joueurs alors c'est vrai qu'on a
vraiment pas beaucoup vu Louis bbaret
alors il a marqué un essai et c'est tant
mieux pour lui pour cette première
sélection en Coupe du Monde il est tout
jeune 20 ans c'est chouette pour lui
mais à part ça c'est vraiment quasiment
la seule action du match je vous le dis
tout de suite il a 5 mètres de chaque
côté non mais c'est vrai bon il fait pas
les il met pas le laisser de l'année
il le met il le met
en plus mais sinon quand même décevons
le joueur ou les joueurs qui nous ont
déçus bon alors Thibault le rugby c'est
un sport colérique
bon d'accord je ne vais pas tout de
suite dire quel est le joueur qui m'a
déçu il y a beaucoup de joueurs qui nous
ont déçus en réalité bon on rentre des
satisfactions on commence par là vous
êtes comme ça d'accord on viendra à aux
joueurs qui ont déçu
des satisfactions bonne rentrée de jeu
longes ça a été un bon galop d'essai
c'est la bonne nouvelle de ce match à
peu près 50
minutes et on l'a vu voilà sans crainte
s'engager sans réserve ça c'est la
première bonne nouvelle je suis d'accord
avec vous Macalou a été entreprenante
parfois un peu maladroit il y a eu
beaucoup de fautes des en avant ce qui
fait aussi son charme mais il a été
entreprenant dynamique et au fond plutôt
rassurant
voilà alors après quand on regarde les
ninzes arrière parce que c'est là où la
déception est la plus forte on voulait
voir moïfana on voulait voir Arthur
Vincent on a été déçu personnellement
j'ai trouvé castoy a été transparent il
y a pas pesé sur le match
germinais était au rendez-vous je sais
pas si ça reste surtout mobilité est
engagée sur les essais je le vois courir
sur le paraissait
uruguayen mais je ne sais pas où est
passé les liés sur le coup de pied qui
amène l'essai Uruguayens mais je dis
jamais rassurant dans son jeu au pied
voilà je dirais voilà à peu près les les
motifs de satisfaction simplement
attention parce qu'on prend beaucoup
d'essais sur ce genre de coup de pied
latéral on a pris le même contre les
Blacks c'est vrai et il y a souvent des
trous sur les ailes et peu d'eau ne
comble pas ses trous il va falloir
je vais demander à Sacha Baudier en
régie d'afficher cette déclaration de
Cameron Cameron woky on lui parle des
pénalités du nombre de pénalités
il est dur avec lui-même et avec son
équipe c'est inadmissible au niveau
international on va parler de ces
erreurs des Bleus on va à Lille vous
Vincent Jean-Marc quel est le joueur les
joueurs qui vous ont déçu
alors moi je partirai d'abord ça
sûrement et fana
boefana on va voilà vous le disiez en
plateau il avait beaucoup à jouer sur ce
sur ce match on le fait rejouer exprès
parce que sur son premier match n'est
pas forcément bon on cherche un
remplaçant un dentier et malheureusement
on a vu une première mi-temps moi j'ai
trouvé en tout cas une première mi-temps
assez compliquée de sa part il y a un
moment où il se perd il sait pas
vraiment quoi faire il fait un an avant
derrière alors que c'est une action ou
les Bleus pourraient aller au bout et on
parlait tout à l'heure antenne avec son
compas du centre je crois que
jean-bragonard n'a pas forcément aimé
son copain du centre Arthur Vincent rate
le placard sur l'essai quand même qui
est marqué très facilement par l'arrière
qui certes et rapide à des cannes mais
tout de même une attaque en première
main comme ça et qu'on tourne la défense
Arthur Vincent le ratjaminera et c'est
Arthur Vincent qui est le premier
placard et qui se fait avoir comme un
comme un joueur de de
Fédérale 3 là c'est vraiment pas
terrible
et moi je suis aussi critique avec la
première ligne qui a débuté parce que je
trouve qu'elle a la deuxième la première
ligne qui a remplacé était de meilleure
facture mais les trois joueurs de
première ligne bourgarites a été un peu
plus vaillant mais il a raté des lancé
en touche il a fait des fautes et les
deux piliers ma foi ont été assez
médiocres ils ont la tête de mêlée a pas
été terrible je veux dire là les cinq
doigts ont pas été très bons et
notamment la première ligne et je pense
que Jean minette fait pas un bon match
il a fait beaucoup d'erreurs alors
certes au pied il a il a un coup de pied
long on le connaît
c'est un bon buteur certes enfin il rate
quand même une pénalité qui n'était pas
très difficile mais moi je trouve qu'il
fait pas il fait pas non plus il est pas
très rassurant enfin il fait pas oublier
Ramos du tout oui et puis c'est un match
où on parie sur les premières lignes
est-ce que emmêlé on s'est dit sur le
sur la première mêlée on s'est dit bon
bah c'est bon on va les plier assez
régulièrement on va gagner des pénalités
et en fait on se rend compte que au fil
du match et ben on n'arrive pas à
prendre l'ascendant sur les mêlés alors
que ça devait être
a fait des
erreurs bêtes quoi quand ils
anticipaient sur la poussée donc on a
pris des pénalités idiotes quand même
quand on est professionnel et qu'on joue
en Top 14 en équipe de France anticiper
la poussée sont fait prendre trois fois
alors attaque qui fintait un peu
l'introduction il jouait avec ça mais
enfin ils ont bien vu que l'arbitre les
surveillait et c'est on a pris une pluie
de pénalité sur des bêtises c'est un
manque de un manque de maîtrise de cette
première ligne à mon avis je lis les
réactions sur Youtube avec notamment
Laurent qui nous dit non c'est je relis
non c'est 60 qui nous dit ça sent bon
pour l'Uruguay contre l'Italie et la
Namibie c'est pas une intéressante elles
ont peut-être une troisième place de
groupe à jouer Alain qui nous salue de
San Francisco le job aurait été de
prendre 5 points et puis sur Le
Figaro.fr un anonyme non restez anonyme
vous faites un petit pseudo comme ça on
peut vous nommer moi fana et Villers
très mauvais ils sont d'accord avec vous
movaka surnage voilà pour les premières
réactions Marc vous avez déjà donné les
joueurs qui vous ont plu je vais
demander à nos amis en plateau Aude
allez s'il y a un joueur a sauvé ce soir
moi j'ai quand même bien aimé janiné je
suis pas tout à fait
d'accord mais pas génial non plus enfin
je veux dire
on verra les notes donner plus tard par
Arnaud et David nos spécialistes rugby
je pense vont être sévères
mais il assure ses points au pied c'est
quand même ce qu'on lui demande et voilà
27 12 l'écart n'est pas non plus tel
qu'on peut se passer des points au pied
aisément donc ça voilà sur sur le pied
c'est quand même satisfaction
je vous taquine je vous taquine
après sur les ponts j'ai eu les j'ai
fait les notes avec mes deux confrères
et
germiné s'en sort pas bien du tout donc
mes deux mes deux confrères dans la
tribune de presse sont d'accord sur le
match d'aujourd'hui
puisque Ramos absolument excellent aux
pieds
un tout petit peu décalé il doit la
mettre aussi et donc là on était sur les
joueurs qu'on a bien aimé oui OK
je voudrais juste revenir sur une chose
vous parliez de la touche Aude et la
mêlée c'est généralement là on voit le
vrai écart international entre des
grosses équipes alors surtout la
performance de la mêlée contre les
blagues qui a été excellent dans on a
pris beaucoup on a été très prétentieux
parce que pendant très longtemps on a
préféré jouer les mêlés qui prendre les
points vous avez raison on a pris
beaucoup de pénalités et dès qu'on
voyait le la mêlée s'effondrer on
pensait que la pénalité était pour nous
un peu par
par évidence et non c'était les
Uruguayens qui poussaient très bien
notamment leur pilier gauche ils
auraient on aurait pu prendre un carton
jaune attention aussi à ce genre de
choses et sinon sur les joueurs que j'ai
bien aimé moi j'ai bien aimé à story
parce que
le débat de la Libération n'était pas
encore tranché il y a quelques temps
[Musique]
mais il a été plutôt rapide dans cette
transmission après il est pas aidé par
par son premier centre moi et fana et il
manquait de course disponibles mais
quand il a eu l'occasion il y a bien un
très bel essai et une passe il déclenche
la passe très rapidement pour bien le
barrer à la fin donc il y a quelque
chose au pluriel intéressantes vous avez
utilisé un mot que je reprends dans le
sondage que je viens de relancer sur
Youtube les blancs ont-ils été
prétentieux oui ça nous intéresse
Jean-Marc est-ce que vous les avez
trouvé prétentieux vous c'est c'est bleu
au début à vouloir jouer tous les
ballons à donner des passes après
placage coûte que coûte comme si tout
allait être facile
moi je les ai trouvés assez suffisant
c'est à dire au rugby il y a une règle
qui est il faut toujours respecter son
adversaire c'est vous apprenez ça à
l'école de rugby et je pense qu'il y a
eu un manque de respect indiscutablement
on a on les a pris de haut et
ils nous ont montré que on avait tort et
il y a effectivement ils ont de bons
joueurs il y avait il y a des gens qui
nous ont surpris je suis absolument
d'accord avec le pilier qui nous a fait
du mal et on a on a vraiment eu le temps
de donner beaucoup de fil à retordre
alors bon l'arbitrage m'a paru un peu un
peu compliqué sur quand on avait des
groupes pénétrants je voyais beaucoup de
maillots jaunes qui étaient infiltrés
dans nos donc excusez toujours l'arbitre
était mieux placer que moi mais il y a
des moments où je me disais quand même
que quand on avait leur pilier gauche
qui en laissait notre talonneur à
l'arrière de notre groupe pénétrange je
pensais pas que c'était sa place normale
mais bon peut-être est-il dit par jeu
moi j'avais le sentiment que oui mais
bon passons sur cette détail mais sur le
fond on a ils nous ont donné du fil à
retordre ils avaient ils ont parlé fort
et nous on les a pris on les a pris de
haut sur les joueurs très bons mais je
voudrais quand même rajouter quelqu'un
parce que il fait toujours des matchs
sensationnels et il est rentré tard
c'est c'est notre talonore remplaçant
qui est exceptionnel encore une fois
parce que quand on parle du mot vaca
quand on parle de l'essai de bielle
biarrhée regardez les deux fois où il
intervient dans cette action à quel
point il accélère le mouvement alors
c'est vrai que derrière astoy finit bien
donne la passe décisive et tout mais
l'action de movaca est une fois de plus
exceptionnel cet homme apporte quelque
chose d'un discutablement dès que le 15
de France là dans ses rang on avance
plus vite il est au soutien il marque un
essai de on dirait dracro mais c'est
parce qu'il est toujours au soutien
qu'il est attrape il attrape ce ballon
quand même c'est pas c'est pas un hasard
si c'était dans ses bras lui que ça
tombe et en plus ils jongle avec le
ballon il ne commet pas d'en avant c'est
un remarquable joueur qui a un à propos
fantastique
23 vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
nous suivre sur Youtube Le Figaro.fr on
reste ensemble encore quelques minutes
et on se demandait à la mi-temps Marc
qu'elle aurait été votre discours pour
essayer de remobiliser ces joueurs quel
est votre discours maintenant là dans le
vestiaire et aller dans les deux trois
quatre jours qui viennent bon je pense
qu'il faut récupérer
tirer les leçons de ce de ce match va
être très difficile
parce que ça a été une partie très
médiocre décousue comme on l'a dit ce
qui est sûr c'est que les les
remplaçants enfin les fournisseurs qui
ont été titulaires n'ont pas marqué des
points voilà c'est je crois que ce qu'on
peut dire j'entendais Jean-Marc sur la
première ligne bah oui on a hâte que que
bah il revienne
parce que on se sent pas très convaincu
par cette cette première ligne on est
rassuré sur bovaka et c'est vrai que il
a fait un match très dynamique quand il
est rentré il a remis un peu l'équipe
dans le sens dans le sens de la marche
donc je dirais bon faire prendre
conscience au joueur qui a encore
beaucoup de chemin que c'est une
compétition
que tous les matchs comptent
dans l'oreillette il faut préparer le
prochain match comme une finale et on
veut se ressaisir il y a un ami alors la
Namibie est peut-être pour un niveau en
dessous et oui mais là il va falloir
montrer que la Namibie est vraiment en
dessous en tout cas il y aura beaucoup
pas démontrer sur le match pour la
Namibie et puis préparer très
sérieusement ce match contre l'Italie il
y a pas de petits matchs aussi le rappel
et le son de ce match d'aujourd'hui Aude
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire contre la
Namibie là j'aimerais pas être Fabien
Galtier
est pas content là on dirait que les
remplaçants des remplaçants était
meilleur notamment parlé de la première
ligne donc est-ce que du coup il faut
faire rentrer cette sorte de troisième
première ligne est-ce que il faut faire
revenir tous les cadres quelques cadres
nous disait avant match très clairement
on fera revenir les cadres contre
l'Italie ce qu'il faut déjà les
ressortir contre la Namibie moi mon avis
personnel là-dessus ce serait que
peut-être ce serait bien dans faire
revenir quelques-uns parce que quand
même on disait tout à l'heure on a
sentiments il manque des leaders il
manque des patrons sur le terrain qui
qui montre l'exemple et puis qui sont
capables de guider un peu leur
partenaire donc on est peut-être pas
obligé de remettre notre 15 de départ
notre 15 premium comme
en tout cas mais peut-être qu'un
soufflet un petit peu quelques joueurs
plus plus patrons peut-être des joueurs
aussi qui ont plus d'automatismes avec
d'autres qui jouent en club ensemble ce
serait peut-être bien un petit peu pour
faire revenir de la confiance parce que
voilà l'anamibie là il faut assurer je
vais m'ouvrir une troisième voie mais je
considère qu'elle finisseur et Galtier a
été très très bon c'est que les
finisseurs sont faits pour être
définisseurs et débutants sont faits
pour être des débutants et on a vraiment
vu le fossé starter pour utiliser un
anglicisme les débutants semblent être
faits pour débuter ces matchs et je ne
pense pas quand je vois 50 minutes
contre la Namibie il risque de des
grosses blessures et ça peut être très
c'est une coupe du monde très longue les
coupes de rugby sont très longues
beaucoup plus étalées que le football
donc attention aussi à mentalement
rester dedans on a une poule hormis les
Blacks relativement facile mais
attention parce que les Sud-Africains
les Irlandais jouent au moins de matchs
de plus à très très haut niveau
Jean-Marc Vincent vous vous en pensez
quoi est-ce que on doit tout remettre en
cause et sortir les tauliers dès la
Namibie est-ce que Antoine Dupont par
exemple doit être titulaire jeudi
prochain c'était pas le plan à la base
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas je ne
sais pas je ne suis pas dans la tête de
Galtier et je sais pas quels sont ces
plans mais il est clair que que Dupont
c'est le patron que quand il est à la
mêlée on voit que on voit qu'ils
commandent la manœuvre et que Lucie
alors le cul pendant un quart d'heure à
mon avis était excellent la charnière a
été formidable mais alors après elle a
plongée comme le reste et il y avait
plus de il y avait plus de patron quoi
il y avait Anthony gelange qui essaie de
tenir ça on y revient qui a fait un
match solide courageux etc mais il a pas
la tendance sur sur ses partenaires et
il a pas la position de donner qui a
Antoine et donc il peut pas commander la
manœuvre comme Antoine le fait parce que
le neuf évidemment le 9 et le 10 sont
les deux sont les deux cerveaux de
l'équipe comme d'habitude dans une
équipe de rugby
mais pour le reste je serais pendant la
tête de Galtier c'est difficile parce
que je pense que ce soir on a perdu
notre statut de favori quelque part et
donc la sérénité qui s'était installée
après la victoire sur les Blacks elle
est un peu à mon avis elle est fracassée
là parce que là on a la profondeur de
banque comme disait Maud etc il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont qui sont
remises en cause là David disait avant
le match il y avait un duel à distance
qui jouait contre l'Irlande et bien a
priori c'est lente qui l'a gagné ce soir
voyons ce que l'Irlande fera dans son
prochain match le Tonga c'est pas facile
non plus mais on va voir
vous avez raison c'était le mon prochain
thème écrit sur la feuille je donne
d'abord le résultat de ce petit sondage
les Bleus ont-ils été prétentieux oui à
64% voilà ce que ce que vous en pensez
peut-on être champion du monde sans banc
est-ce qu'on peut être champion du monde
à 15 c'est possible bien sûr alors on
n'est pas passé loin mais vous regardez
au final de coupe du monde
qui est à la fin de la Coupe du monde
extérieur non l'équipe qui peut être
champion du monde c'est celle qui arrive
à sur deux trois postes clés c'est déjà
beaucoup en rugby arrive à faire les
changements sans casser la dynamique du
groupe sans casser sans vexer personne
mais à faire quand même les changements
qui veillent et ce ne serait-ce pas
parce qu'on a gagné les blagues avec
cette équipe titulaire qu'il ne faudra
pas revoir certaines choses notamment je
longe à qui on doit quand même insérer
un sacré coup de chapeau parce que on ne
revient pas des croisés au bout de 6
mois à ce niveau là normalement c'est 8
ou 9 tous les médecins vous le diront et
surtout en commençant tout de suite un
si bon niveau
est-ce qu'on peut être champion du monde
sans banc
alors Fabien Galtier et puis c'est c'est
toute son équipe parle beaucoup de la
notion de groupe en disant voilà on
n'est pas 15 dans cette équipe on est on
est plus ça c'est le discours
le problème c'est que là on a vu quand
même les limites on voit bien qu'en tout
cas on n'a pas deux équipes France alors
pas du même niveau bien sûr ça on s'y
attendait mais là le la différence est
énorme et clairement contre la Namibie
et ensuite contre l'Italie il va falloir
se rétablir parce que ensuite quand on
affrontera j'espère
l'Afrique du Sud ou l'Irlande alors là
ce sera quand même tout autre mayonnaise
et il faudra élever son niveau de
plusieurs crans
vous partagez la vie de jean-margonin le
statut de favori affiché la semaine
dernière
on peut le replier pour l'instant bon je
pense quand même que c'est pas sur ce
type de match qu'on doit tirer des
conclusions définitives sur le statut de
favori ou pas de l'équipe de France on
sait que ça va être une coupe du monde
très disputée l'équipe d'Irlande est à
très haut niveau elle a remporté de
manière incontestable le Tournoi des six
nations et l'abattu toutes les nations
majeures au passage d'ailleurs sa
dernière défaite c'est contre le All
Blacks
à abattu et puis il y a eu comme
d'habitude une grosse Afrique du Sud
avec des gros moyens physiques mais qui
vient de perdre son talonneur
emblématiques
Malcom Marx qui est blessé qui ne jouera
pas ce qui est à mon avis
dans cet équipe donc je dirais pour
répondre plus précisément à votre
question est-ce qu'on peut gagner sans
bon bien sûr que non en revanche
c'est pas tout le bon
qui a sombré dans ce match rappelle
quand même que sur un banc il y a une
majorité d'avant cinq ou six
et que
dans les finisseurs de l'équipe de
France il y a des joueurs qui ont pas
des mérités et quand il entre en cours
de jeu quand ils rentrent en cours de
jeu ils sont bons c'est peut-être
qu'il n'y a pas deux équipes de France
voilà une équipe de France complète
non mais en revanche il y a une
vingtaine de joueurs je crois que c'est
ça la conclusion finalement de ce match
sur lequel Fabien Galtier peut compter
le reste c'est plus questionnable
Jean-Marc ou enfant est-ce que 12
changements c'était trop et est-ce que
cette équipe de France peut être
championne du monde sans bon sans
doublure performante
je suis de la vie de marque là je suis
je pense qu'il y a une il y a quand même
il y a un noyau dur qui est supérieur à
15 joueurs indiscutablement il y a des
gens de bon niveau il y a des vous avez
des joueurs qui à mon avis ont montré
leur limite et sur lesquels Gatier
pourra pas compter pour les matchs
disons la phase finale les à partir des
quarts de finale il faut qu'il y ait la
ceinture et qui tiennent à 15 à une
vingtaine de joueurs un peu en dessous
de 25 mais il y a vous avez il manque il
y a des manques on discutablement alors
après bon il y aura les blessures après
on connaît les aléas de ce sport on voit
combien dans toutes les équipes
d'ailleurs il y a des blessés mais ça va
être ça va être juste je pense pas qu'on
est enfin le discours de Galtier avait
été tellement on met tout le monde le
même niveau on a on a un squat
formidable ben non là on s'aperçoit que
pas tout à fait dans la même mesure pour
pour tout le monde on s'est bien rendu
compte que notamment de le paquet
d'avant qui ont été dominateur au départ
n'a pas fait ses preuves
pendant le match quoi il y a eu on se
fait malmener par des iruboyens c'est
dit sans mépris mais même en technicité
en stratégie c'était très brouillon les
ils sont des joueurs individuellement
très forts les Uruguayens mais tout de
même envoyé bien leur technique
collective était nettement en dessous et
on s'est fait embrouiller et nos joies
n'ont pas gardé la lucidité face à face
cette espèce de tourment de jaune qui
les a ça y est quoi c'est assez
inquiétant ça je dois dire pour une
coupe du monde on n'a pas on n'a pas
tout à fait le squat qu'il faut pour
pour naviguer sur toutes les eaux quoi
remontez pas le moral Jean-Marc gonna
merci messieurs tiens
allez-y jean-marcisson
non non je voulais simplement dire le
coup de pied de déplacement là qui tombe
dans les bras de l'ailier
ça c'est de la vidéo toutes les équipes
nous ont étudiées ont étudié notre
défense et on se le prend chaque fois
c'était cela donc tout le monde nous
regarde et les Italiens ils ont fait
tourner le disque dur sont plein et je
peux vous dire je les ai vu jouer
j'étais à Saint-Étienne dimanche dernier
leur paquet d'avant il est bien
supérieur à celui du revois donc ça va
être compliqué un message à Fabien
Galtier Jean-Marc je lui dis tout ce que
vous venez de nous dire ça devrait aller
merci messieurs tiens la différence
d'ambiance entre le Stade de France et
Lille ça s'est senti est-ce qu'il y a un
public plus festif moins connaisseur ce
que ça peut se sentir ça lorsqu'on est
en tribune
tout ce qu'on a vu nous alors moi ce que
je dirais c'est qu'en tout cas
l'ambiance est absolument géniale une
nouvelle fois à part les moments que je
vous ai dit ou le tout ou le stade c'est
lui mais bon le score était pas
forcément pour nous mais en tout cas sur
les 10 premières minutes du match
c'était incroyable comme ambiance comme
l'ambiance incroyable qu'on a vu au
Stade de France je veux compléter parce
que nos hôtels sont en ville et en ville
c'est génial vraiment on voit que comme
on dit dans le Nord il y a des
estaminets il y a de la bière ça va très
bien supporter de rugby plus comme vous
savez dans le Nord la bière est assez
costaud et ma foi les terrasse était
pleine il y avait de belles ambiance en
ville des heures avant le match et on
parle bien évidemment de la bière pour
les supporters
j'ai compris le message tout à l'heure
Vincent avant le match parce que vous
vouliez vite rentrer j'ai compris aussi
le message vous voulez boire un petit
une petite menthe à l'eau hein avec
modération évidemment merci messieurs on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine et nous
on finit avec Tanguy soyez bonsoir
Tanguy merci journaliste au service
réseau sociaux que s'est-il dit sur les
internet alors je vous êtes friand de
statistiques je vais vous en abreuver
allez vu pendant cette rencontre 868 à
la minute c'est bien ça fait 170 000 ans
tous et trois fois moins que contre les
Blacks donc une activité moindre même si
les on peut penser que les gens se sont
rendus sur sur Twitter pour manifester
leur mécontentement alors ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est le graphique que
je vais vous montrer sur les joueurs qui
ont sur qui les tweets sont le plus
réagi oui c'est celui-là alors je me
retourne comme ça
avec 1176 116 tweets pour souligner à la
fois sa réussite au pied mais aussi
c'est carence dans le jeu courant il y a
eu aussi Gabin Villiers en numéro 2 646
tweet
aussi assez transparent on peut le dire
j'imagine que c'est plutôt des tweets
qu'il critiquent
voilà et puis Louis bielle biarrhée
peut-être porté par son essai à la fin
du match dans les Twitter sont partis
nous sommes proches de nos internautes
exactement
donc c'est Melvin Jaminet qui est bon
lui a été plutôt correct au pire en tout
cas très correct au pied oui absolument
continuer mon cher Tanguy alors sur le
le prochain tweet j'ai voulu le mettre
parce que c'est vrai que il y a des
joueurs qui peuvent nourrir des regrets
il faisait partie vous savez de ce
fameux groupe des 42 au départ
sélectionné par farming Galtier ils
n'ont pas été retenus dans les 33 on
pense à gaeton Ethan du mortier Mathis
Lebel qui aurait peut-être fait du bien
à l'aile à la place de peut-être Gabin
Villiers ou Louis Biel biarrhée et puis
Baptiste serin on sait qu'il y a une
grosse concurrence au poste de 2000 mêlé
voilà donc ce Twitter prêchait plutôt
pour pour sa paroisse parce qu'on voit
que c'est un compte de Stade Toulousain
et là on repart pour une heure là
il y a aussi un fait assez étonnant pas
enfin pas très étonnant mais en tout cas
qui a été noté dans le dans le prochain
tweet c'est les Français évidemment
orphelins de Damian penault leur ultime
Sauveur qui fait qui fait tellement de
bien notre équipe de France
qui ressort à la place d'Antoine Dupont
c'est peut-être lui le détonateur
finalement
populaire et puis on sait qu'il a il a
toujours cette cette percée qui fait mal
en cours de match il est il est friands
de ce retour vers l'intérieur donc ça
c'était sur
ce soir c'est vrai l'état de la pelouse
aussi qui a qui a fait réagir nos twitos
on sait que les jardiniers du LOSC
notamment vont avoir du travail avec on
voit cette mode de vie le club de
football qui joue d'habitude dans ce
stade Pierre Mauroy le club de Lille et
alors là je vous coupe c'est le
commentaire qui agace autre variété
c'est que c'est vraiment à chaque fois
sur chaque pelouse qui n'est qui n'est
pas on va dire
à chaque fois à chaque fois chaque fois
ça revient mais bon c'est drôle la
première fois la deuxième fois peut-être
la dixième fois bon la cinquième fois au
bout d'un moment je trouve que la blague
à 23h39 sur des mêlés comme ça que là de
la pelouse se soulève et puis pour
terminer un tweet assez léger assez
drôle vous allez voir le lien avec le
football et Kylian Mbappe alors ce
Twitter a voulu finir sur une note assez
positive je vais vous lire ce tweet fut
une époque on aurait perdu ce match
gagné d'avance au lieu de ça on a géré
tranquillement on note aussi la légère
ironie avec cette fameuse phrase le
rugby il a changé et la la référence à
Kylian Mbappe qui avait tenu cette
phrase de football il a changé avec son
club du Paris Saint-Germain qui a fait
le tour des réseaux sociaux lors du
match contre la Nouvelle-Zélande c'est
rendu dans le vestiaire qui comprenait
rien et c'est ça il célébrer les essais
une ou deux secondes après les autres
alors que Marc fuyer les célèbre avant
parce qu'il voit venir merci
juste c'est vrai que ça faisait
longtemps qu'on avait pas vu une équipe
de France décevante on en pendant des
années on était content là ces dernières
années ça allait mieux on sait que
c'était terminé
de parcours et on croise vraiment les
doigts pour la Namibie merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'être venu sur plateau
pour donner votre votre avis merci
Mercury directeur général du Figaro
devenu merci au bariletti journaliste au
service société tanguyez des réseaux
sociaux
Augustin Moriot évidemment s'il
programme aussi cette soirée avec
Virginie le trioner Germain Fido à la
réalisation Clément réitère était au son
Sacha body à l'édition qui nous donne
les statistiques qui me parlent dans
l'oreillette et puis évidemment le tout
sous la honnête de Vincent ou à la
rédaction en chef merci de nous avoir
suivi bon c'est pas une grande soirée on
va gagner on a vu pire et on se retrouve
jeudi prochain merci beaucoup salut